and welcome to hannity
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 73
we're not going to give up thinking
about praying for hoping and reminding
all of the country that it's now 73 days
and tonight the official number of
americans still trapped in afghanistan
continues to rise first it was oh they
told us under a hundred left then it was
a couple hundred now we're getting
closer and closer to a thousand tonight
in other words that the biden
administration doesn't really know how
many americans that joe biden left
behind and they sure as hell don't know
how many thousands of green card holders
that he also abandoned and their
families it's day 73 and this is still a
complete total utter disaster
what's going to happen if isis or one of
these terror groups gets a hold of these
americans
what do you think their future will hold
for them according to one top pentagon
official tonight isis k in afghanistan
could have the capability to attack the
u.s in six to 12 months but guess what
joe biden doesn't care he's turned the
page it's like it never happened the
media mob they've turned the page with
them and tonight well joey's a few miles
away from the white house he is in
northern virginia campaigning for long
time clinton hack terry mcauliffe take a
look
my name is joe biden i'm jill biden's
husband
the real reason i'm here tonight
is
my wife jill teaches full time at
northern virginia community college
[Applause]
and terry's going to be her boss
terry's opponent
doesn't like to talk about how
very much now
but to win the republican nomination he
embraced donald trump the new bridge
that we built next to the 117 year old
long bridge in arlington
this will be dedicated corridor to
passenger rail and reduced traffic
bottlenecks and freight rail it'll be a
game changer
vote
[Applause]
so kind to joe to dedicate his precious
time and energy to the mcauliffe
campaign and it's not often that joey
gets away from the white house
especially this late at night
probably had to take a long nap today
especially to campaign for a guy terry
mcauliffe who announced that joe's
horrible performance in office was
actually dragging him down he's the
reason that this is such a tough race in
the blue state of virginia take a look
we got to get democrats out to vote we
are facing a lot of headwinds from
washington as you know the president
is unpopular today unfortunately here in
virginia so we have got to plow through
oh it's true joe biden is deeply
unpopular after a series of massive
self-inflicted crises his approval
numbers are hovering in the mid-30s he's
underwater in every single poll his
polling average is at an all-time low
but apparently with mccullough's
opponent glenn younkin now picking up
momentum desperate times call for
desperate measures but i hate to break
it to you terry
everything joe biden touches absolutely
implodes afghanistan could have been
prevented imploded the border imploded
his handling of covert 19 we have more
dead americans in 2021 than we did in
2020. the economy biden inflation gas
prices foreign policy china iran north
korea russia you name it he couldn't
even negotiate a submarine deal with
australia without causing a massive
diplomatic crisis now this rally seems
like a last-minute hail mary between two
deeply unlikable dishonest career
political hacks who have dedicated their
entire lives to what is known as the
sewer the swamp of washington d.c